فقالت صحيفه الفايناشول تايمز ان المبعوثه
الامريكيه الى ايران روبرت مالي اجتمع
مرات عده بالمندوب الايراني في الامم
المتحده امير سيد ايرافاني وقالت ان هذه
اللقاءات تعد اول لقاء مباشر بين الولايات
المتحده ومسؤولين ايرانيين منذ اعلان
الرئيس الامريكي السابق في 2018 الانسحاب
من الاتفاق النووي وقالت الصحيفه ان هذه
اللقاءات بين مالي والدبلوماسي الايراني
بحثت امكانيه تبادل اسرى بين الطرفين كما
قالت الصحيفه انه كانت هناك اتصالات بين
مسؤولين غربيين وايرانيين في الاشهر
الاخيره بما في ذلك اجتماع عقد في العاصمه
النرويجيه اوسلو في مارس اذار الماضي بين
مسؤولين من فرنسا والمانيا والمملكه
المتحده مع رئيس فريق التفاوض الايراني في
الملف النووي
نبقى في الملف الايراني حيث قال قائد
البحريه الايرانيه لادميرال شاهرام ايران
ان بلاده ستشكل اختلافات جديده تشمل
القوات البحريه بين ايران وعده دول واضاف
ان القوات البحريه الايرانيه مقبله على
التعاون المشترك مع دول المنطقه بما في
ذلك السعوديه والهند والامارات وقطر
والبحرين والعراق وباكستان
في اشاره الى تحالف البحري بين ايران
وروسيا والصين قال ايراني العسكريه
الثلاثيه شمال المحيط الهندي في طور
التوسع باتجاه دول اخرى
وبخصوص اللقاءات بين روبرت ماليا المبعوثه
الامريكي لايران ومندوب ايران في الامم
المتحده والذي نقلتهينز
نسال مراسلنا من طهران نور الدين الدغير
عن ما اكدته طهران بخصوص هذا اللقاء او
هذه اللقاءات
الى التاريخ الدقيق لهذا اللقاء بل تحدثت
على ان لقاءات حدثت خلال الاشهر الماضيه
لكن في مضمونه ربما قد يتماشى مع ما يحدث
من مستجدات التي نشهدها الان خاصه على
مستوى الموضوع الرئيسي الذي ارسلت اليه
الصحيفه وهي مساله تبادل السجناء ما بين
ايران والولايات المتحده نلاحظ ان هناك
وتيره مرتفعه وتتزايد على مستوى هذا الملف
بدات بالتبادل السجناء ما بين ايران وما
بين بلجيكا وكذلك مشاهدنا وامس عن اطلاق
سراح مجموعه من السجناء من النمساويين
وكذلك الدنماركيين عبر الوساطه العمانيه
والوسط البلجيكيه هذا ربما قد يقرا على ان
السياق المقبل والذي تدخل عليه ايران مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو بالدرجه
الاولى في الدرجه الاولى هو سياق البحث عن
صفقه ما من اجل تبادل سجناء يحملون
الجنسيه المزدوجه الايرانيه الامريكيه هنا
بايران مع مطالب اخرى ايرانيه ربما قد
تشمل عن مبالغ ماليه في كوريا الجنوبيه او
بالعراق وكما نعلم على ان هذه المساله
كذلك تتم عبر وساطه عمانيه وكثير من تحدث
في هذا الموضوع خاصه بعد زياره سلطان عمان
الى طهران فتم الحديث على ان هناك ملفات
تحل لكن الموضوع الاساسي والمهم احينما
نتحدث عن حرحله هذا الملف ربما قد يقرا
كذلك على انه خطوه مهمه جدا في اطار حلحله
الملفات العالقه ما بين ايران والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والمجموعه الغربيه وهنا
بالتحديد حينما نذهب للحديث عن مساله
الاتفاق النووي عن مساله البرنامج النووي
عن مساله الملف النووي ونربط ذلك بالتقرير
الاخير لدى الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
والذي اشار الى ان بعض الاشكالات العالقه
ما بين ايران والوكاله الدولي والوكاله
الدولي للطاقه الذريه خاصه فيما يخص بعض
الاماكن النوويه
منطقه ماريفان وكذلك حول اليورانيوم
المرتفع التقصير بالنسبه تتجاوز الثمن
الفئه على انه تم حل هذا حلحله هذا
الموضوع فهذا قد يعطي انطباعا ما على ان
هناك خطوات ربما تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار
باتجاه ربما حل الملف الاكبر وهو الملف
النوعي اذا في سياق ما يحدث الان في سياق
التقلبات الاقليميه والتغيرات التي تشهدها
المنطقه وكذلك على المستوى العالمي يمكن
القول بان هناك خطوات تحدث من اجل الافراج
عن مجموعه من الملفات العالقه ما بين
ايران قد يكون ملف تبادل الاسرى احدى اهم
من ملفاتها الذي وهو الذي اشرت اليه
الصحيفه وربما قد يكون ذلك مقدمه خاصه اذا
ما علمنا ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كانت تحدثت في وقت سابق تقول بان اتمام
صفقه الاتفاق النووي يجب ان تتم خلاله
عمليه تبادل الاسرع لذلك يبقى السؤال هل
يمكن الحديث الان على ان صفقه تبادل
الاسرى وصلت الى نقطه اساسيه ربما هذا ما
سيسفر سيخرج عنه المستقبل ما يخص
المفاوضات الجاريه الان وهل سيؤدي ذلك الى
حلله عقده الاتفاق النووي كذلك هذا يبقى
مرهون بكل هذه الاجراءات القائمه الان بين
ايران والولايات المتحده الامريكيه سواء
عما تحدثت عنه صحيفه
للشؤون الايرانيه او ما ستسفر عنه التي
تتحدث عنها الخارجيه الايرانيه على ان
هناك تبادل للرسائل ما بين ايران
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه عن طريق
وسطاء اذا كل هذا يعطي انطباع ان ما يتحرك
باتجاه الحلحله لكن سيصل الى نهايات سعيده
ربما هذا السؤال هو المطروح على المستقبل
وعلى الوسطات القائمه الان من طهران شكرا
لك